all right and we are sort of live
and welcome to the Ireland podcast LLC
and also on lordsofgaming.net episode
number 292 the bonus episode it's not a
glorious Monday we were back at the
round table of the Lord's day I'm
extremely excited about our special
guest and we've got tango games work and
the massive success of Hi-Fi rush so we
go get right into it
I want to introduce the Lord whose dream
project of rhythm-based action gameplay
City drives with an exceptional visual
art style has literally transformed Chai
at 808 from wannabe rock stars to two of
the coolest future mascots of Xbox
introducing the game designer at Tango
Gameworks a game director on the iconic
evil within two and the high five Rush
franchise
the Lord of Feel Good Vibes who keeps us
rocking to The Beat
still a B Store Guitar Hero live whose
studio is responsible for the best
Shadow drop of 2023
live from the Land of the Rising Sun by
way of New York we found out kind enough
to make his debut into the realm of the
Lord my man Lord John Johannes of Tango
gainsworth how you doing sir
I'm doing great nice to be here
good to have you good to have you a lord
at what you do man it's only right we
show you the proper respect in the round
table so um first of all have you got a
chance to play anything through all this
craziness uh I've been actually playing
my game now to make sure it's working on
my Xbox
uh yeah other than that
um I've actually just been watching
streams of people playing the game uh
rather than me playing anything new
myself so
since it's come out I haven't played
anything yet have you been soaking it in
is it is it just still you're still in
the Whirlwind of it all
yeah I'm chasing people like trying to
find every last secret as well as like
people who are getting stuck on stuff
I've actually but I'm like a cat game
dancer like reaching out on Twitter and
trying to like be like hey you should
try this you should try this
absolutely you put it in an extra work
they're due diligence you know First
Development I do yeah they'll they'll
and of course we have the four horse
would have gave me here in the realm the
original Lords of the realm and a round
table so that's all you could not make
it but he sent his questions and his
love so we got my co-host the co-host my
brother from another mother the
difficult game conqueror Lord of his old
world and the how of the young wolf Lord
addict of the attic show are we doing
something
doing pretty good you know I didn't
really play much of anything yesterday I
ended up uh bench watching all of the
Lord of the Rings somehow I don't know
how that happened I don't know why I
started the first one but I started the
first one and then before I know it I
was ending the third one so uh you know
I definitely appreciate you guys coming
on here it's but it's definitely an
interview that I've been looking forward
to no doubt and of course returning we
have the Incredible Hulk of this aka the
excess gamer the prophet of Xbox Swami
King of the statues there is nothing
less than that premium experience it is
the leader of the fraud alert movement
oh beloved little King how are we doing
sir hope you feel about it I'm doing
extra fantastic with actually a little
bit of sleep no I did not pass away
people
uh no but um I've been having a good
time actually uh caught up on a lot of
games that I had on the back burner and
a shadow drop game that I didn't know
that I had to play as my much as I
wanted to play it once I saw it I knew I
had to download it so we all know what
that is that's high five Rush yeah so um
you know we talked about it enough but
now we bring you the man the myth The
Legend and we're going to get into this
game I am super excited for this right
here
and of course we have the game Ninja
himself the Shinobi Lord Cognito
spreading that real estate and rubbing
IOP not tell you what you want to hear
but what you need to hear again nothing
but Hi-Fi Rush man ended it and uh yeah
we got a lot to talk about today so we
go get into it man so now that we kind
of got the intros out the way you know
we got to focus on um Lord John John
this man his video game system history
his journey into game development at the
legendary Tango Gameworks and of course
what led him to writing and directing
one of the brightest surprise hits of
the Xbox and the Bethesda developer
direct so Lord John let's start from the
beginning what we're coming to some of
the first video game systems you had and
what got you into gaming
oh man uh so I actually grew up in one
of those homes where you're not supposed
to play video games
um so I go to other people's houses and
play games but um I think the first
system that I actually was able to have
was the Super Nintendo
um and then from there uh I just kind of
found you know or was able to get my
hands on any system afterwards and I
wasn't you know
it's like I wasn't a Nintendo person or
like a psycho person I was like and
anything would go as long as it was fun
um yeah so I would basically be playing
pretty much everything and then when I
went to University maybe I like you know
dropped off a little bit but then I came
back afterwards what brought you back
what brought you back if you remember I
don't know I'm trying to think uh uh in
a weird way so I
throughout University I kind of just
like focused on studying and stuff
um but then afterwards I moved to Japan
one of the first games I played when I
came back when I went to Japan was uh
Persona 4 goal yeah which is weird
because I was living in the countryside
if you know that game it takes place in
like a Countryside town so
I got super into that and then I was
just like that's what that was after I
played that when the PS3 is already out
so then I'm like you know what let me
get PS3 and then you know I just could
have went from there and got spiraled
out of control again yes
getting any questions before we move on
to gaming no no no no no
um I was going to ask him about his
rhythm-based video game history
and there because uh first time I got a
chance to see Guitar Hero or Dance Dance
Revolution was in arcades and being that
she in the Land of the Rising Sun
and I know that's huge over there was
that your first experience into the uh
you know the beat genre or was it a Home
console that got you in like you was
over somebody's house and you saw it and
was like oh let me get into that
I think the first rhythm game I ever
played was PaRappa the Rapper
shout out
like I don't even think it would maybe
it was possible before that but I think
you know with the PlayStation and like
the the audio systems that they had I
think that was the first time you can
kind of pull that off
um and I love that game so much unique
art style yeah again yeah that's the
type of thing that like
you know we can get into it later but
when you think about that kind of era
where it's like they just wanted to try
something cool that was fun and play
around with something that looked cool
as well
um you know it wasn't a really long game
it was like six songs only but it like
it's something that I could say now and
all of us go yeah like you remember that
one right so look around oh yeah that
definitely definitely had a good he gave
me his incredible questions for uh Lord
John oh no not really well you know you
pretty much asked I was gonna ask the
random question and King beat me to it
that's what king likes doing is beating
these questions
look we'll be going because I know we
can talk gaming for a long time you know
what I mean we definitely want to
respect your time but uh we gotta we
gotta discuss like that unique Journey
because you know I looked at you know
your history Lord John and what seems
very unique to me is like how you know
on one hand like you transformed from
this like language teacher to then go to
Japan to teach English and then become
from a game developer like this is like
mind-blowing to me so like kind of walk
us through like that Journey as far as
getting into game development
uh uh yeah so my path is not a
traditional one I don't think uh
I basically just applied for something
on a website with no experience
whatsoever it was yeah it's one of those
things it was um you know I was in Japan
already I was doing something called the
jet program which uh people familiar
with Japan are in general maybe know it
but it's an opportunity to go to the to
Japan and teach in schools and help with
their English language programs
um but they normally send you to Parts
outside of the city like you don't go to
Central Tokyo and do it you do kind of
in the in the countryside
um so I was there and it was a great
experience in general but also there was
not a lot to do especially if you're in
the countryside so I just spend a lot of
time just studying Japanese and when I
was kind of finishing that up I was
looking thinking what I was going to do
next I thought I might want to go to
graduate school and study Japanese
literature or something I did in college
and wanted to get into it but I found
this uh you know obviously I said it
kind of got back into games during this
period
um I found this basically blog post
saying hey the the founder of resident
or the creative Resident Evils making a
new studio in Tokyo and there was like a
link to the website looked at the
website and I'm looking at all the
positions there with no intention to
actually apply to anything so I'm just
like okay let me see what this is and
the only things that say that they're
looking for is like people who want to
make games people who like games people
who have passion for games
yeah but like no you know it's very
specific uh you know you need to have
like four to five years experience with
this engine or something like that I was
like
all right you know what like let me
write a cover letter because uh you know
that you know the creative Resident Evil
my boss she would call me you know not
just yeah not just Resident Evil but
like weirdly enough for me I was super
into at that point uh Ace Attorney
[Laughter]
when she didn't even make he produced
but like the you know the sort of he's
known for kind of like making very well
made games as well as sort of producing
these interesting ideas so I was like
you know what let me give it a try and I
kind of just sent like my resume in a
cover letter and be like I have no game
experience I don't know what you're
doing but I want to help make something
especially for like a like a global
audience as well so it doesn't feel like
you know it was we're kind of getting
into that era where Japanese games were
like struggling on the PS3
um they're feeling very Japanese and
maybe International markets were weren't
going for them and I was like
you know I just want to be there maybe
early on to help out and you know
provide insight and stuff like that
they called me in for an interview we
just talked about games and I was
offered a spot on the team which is at
that point 20 people Max you know it's a
new studio and people are doing like
multiple jobs and I sort of just like
wormed my way into the game development
conversation since I was we're all
sitting together you know and uh
and then there became a point it's like
well do you want to be on the game
design team and I was like yeah and you
know and that's how it kind of just
started
um and then it was just basically
learning is going so I didn't have any
training or or anything like that so wow
that that
bed
when you think about this man jumping on
the team like that how do you feel about
hearing that story from job yeah I I
guess it's definitely not the norm uh I
don't know too many scenarios that
that's happened but you know especially
being you know in Japan you know really
going up to a studio like that and you
said you you know you definitely was a
gaver at that time but at that time I I
assumed you wasn't playing a whole whole
lot at that time
because you're doing the your studies
and stuff uh so it was definitely I
would say
when it comes to you know applying that
what kind of like
what kind of anxiety did you have going
into something you ain't never done
before
uh well for like like for the job
interview or something I wasn't anxious
because I was like I didn't really
expect again
he shot his shot you gotta respect
yes he doesn't expect to get it he's got
the job you're like who me yeah I
basically I went in there with the thing
of like
in that best scenario here is I get to
say I worked in a in a game company for
like six months before nope throw that
right on the resume
what that was yeah um but then when I
was in there I would you know I think
like it was like pretty much every day I
was like oh I don't know I don't know
what I'm doing so like I'm gonna get
fired tomorrow
every day for the first yeah six months
but um but yeah like it you know in a
weird way when you get into the game
industry you realize that there's not
really a a science per se to how to make
a game
um a lot of it's like discussion and
thinking of what's fun what works so
when I kind of realized that I realized
okay it's okay to like make mistakes and
try stuff and Pitch stuff and it's not
going to go well and uh and never get
too attached to certain things as well
but
yeah first couple days definitely
anxiety inducing then it kind of calmed
down that makes sense I love to hear it
man that's a very inspiring story shoot
your shot and then obviously you're at
Tango you're working with the legendary
makami and um so my understanding that
you go from Evil you start like kind of
like Evil Within DLCs that kind of thing
and then to where we are now which is
kind of like this this this magic thing
that's happened so I want to start with
like the pitch of Hi-Fi rush because
it's be honest it's such it's a really
departure from Tango kind of
culture-wise you know what I'm saying
like you got this rhythm-based game you
got all this you know throwback feel
almost Dreamcast like energy kick like
it's it's like I I want to go through
that pitch process first and then like
any other game Inspirations because
again I'm feeling feeling some Sega
Vibes I'm feeling a little Zeno gears
I'm getting a little crash
drama I'm getting all this stuff in it
so like the pitch The Inspirations like
walk us through that
uh yeah so I mean the pitch goes to
where the basically where the
inspiration was where for a long time I
just had this idea of like you know when
you see a trailer or a movie or uh
especially music videos especially like
in the late 90s and stuff like that when
they had like the budget to do it they
would coordinate everything to the music
and it would just feel really good
really tight you know and
I never felt like we got that experience
here with like the an action game
um and in my mind I was just like man it
would be cool if we could make a game
where everything sinks to a music track
but this was like way way back but
probably I would almost say like 10
years before I even pitched it
internally because the idea is cool but
I was like how can you actually pull it
off and
after we finish the evil within two
um we knew that the next game and that
we were going to production was close by
Tokyo and so we have these kind of like
dark games another one that's coming up
that may not be a horror game for say
but it was kind of still in that sort of
Moody dark Moody atmosphere and um at
that point I kind of had I'm oh I would
always come back to this idea and I said
okay this is like a 180 from whatever
we're doing but
we know what's coming up if we're going
to work on something now if we're going
to try to do it a turn like this or do
something interesting now it's like now
is the chance to do it so the same thing
is like shoot your shot it's like I'll
do it now and try to pitch it so I
pitched it basically how it is in the
game it's it's very bizarre for like a
pitch to like work out its way into the
final product but yeah because I mean
like if it doesn't work you just redo it
a bunch of times but um yeah it was just
like okay this is a game where it's a
rhythm action game where every hit and
every punch like hits to the music and
it just feels like you're part of a
music video and the basic plot was there
it's like you're someone who's uh gets
this like robotic arm replacement like a
music player Falls in their chest you
team with a bunch of little eyes and
take down the boss of this this tech
company like one boss at a time that was
on there
um and the same thing with the colorful
style oh yeah like I'm like
I've used things from the PS2 era and
the Dreamcast era and yes and said you
know remember when the times your games
were just like colorful and fun looking
it's like this is a game that doesn't
take itself seriously it's gonna be over
the top you're gonna look at it you're
gonna say it's fun has these like
over-the-top characters and again this
is all in the is on the pitch and when I
was explaining it
um you know the first thing I did when I
put that on the table was like this is
probably not going to get past the state
because this is the most unbethesda
thing you can never imagine
um us doing and
and but I just kept going into it I just
like I kind of remember was like
physically explained it too I was like
you know how like every punch and every
and I was like physically doing it and
then by the end it was clear that there
was like a very strong passion behind
this idea that my boss kind of saw as
like this seems like a very tricky thing
to pull off but obviously you have like
a good concept you have in your mind so
let's see where this could go
um that question that question I got a
question since you said you're mine
right
When You Close Your Eyes
did the game look in your head like how
it looks now good question
uh
uh the visual the visual identity wasn't
there but I knew it was going to have
this like blue skies like colorful look
like it had to like right there was no
way I could pull off like a with rhythm
fighting game with music player in the
chest with like realistic characters and
things like that definitely not yeah but
let's go for that High Ground
realistic Fidelity on that all right but
you wanted to be departed away from that
anyway you went to carve out your own
like like identity and because this game
is so like you said like such a
departure from what they've been doing
and your pitch sound probably so super
refreshing because I'm pretty sure when
when they hired you
saw some type of passion right and it
just all accumulated to this one point
in this pitch meeting the reason why
you're there right because you know you
said hey six months I'm out of here but
no
we get past the six month part and
you're here with with this pitch and
because a lot of times when we draw I
used to draw as a child
and I give it to my friend so he can
bring it to life and it looked like how
I wanted it to look but I wanted to know
did the artist really capture the
character because you got like a Peter
Parker type of cat right there you said
queens and it he feels really queenish
like it's like he has this queen swag So
when you say you're from Queens I'm like
oh my God you got Peter Parker I see
what you're doing I see what you did
I mean I don't know if it the like I
said the visual identity like shy would
look like this or at that point didn't
even have a name but right it's
you knew that it kind of had to have
this like silly like Spirit to it yeah
and that's what I knew that we needed to
have is not just from a personal
perspective but almost from like a
company perspective
um from our studio you know the studio
is founded not just to make horror games
um and mikami's always been vocal about
that like you know it's about reading
new ideas and and if it's interesting if
it's worth making we should make it
um so this kind of maybe was also like a
chance for people in the studio to get
to like stretch their legs and and try
something new as well and not get like
pigeonholed into the same like Loop over
and over again
um and it was the same way with the the
art design it was like we had artists
that were literally like 10 years
working on you know like like blood
scrape walls and stuff like that and
like Rusty corridors and to ask them to
be like hey okay we're gonna go
everything's gonna be super colorful
um there could have been a lot of like
pent up like enter energy in there from
like not being able to do that for a
while thank God yeah
but yeah I think there was a little bit
of that but also I think it was just a
fun challenge to see like how far can we
take this and go with it and we didn't
want to make it feel like anything else
too we wanted to kind of put our spin on
whatever we were going to do so it
wasn't just like a copy paste thing that
we wanted to do so
yeah real quick question when you take
this newer type of game to uh developers
that you know has been working on games
like The Evil Within for for a good
amount of time and you bring up like
this newer concept and you know this
newer art style where they did uh was
they extremely excited to work on
something new like that
uh definitely some people were and some
people maybe weren't at first you had to
like convince them uh because it's like
a departure from both genres like it's
not a rhythm game per se and it's not
like a straight action game per se so
when you go to somebody who's like I've
worked on action before
um it's you can't you can't combine
these two elements it's gonna it's gonna
conflict with each other and I'm like no
no we can do this we can do this
um but then some people were like really
into it like the sound teams into it and
figuring out different ways how to make
it work they said the art team was into
it
um I think there was some maybe uh worry
for example like um some of the RT like
the environments and the characters like
can they pull it off like when you're
doing animation and stuff in in a real
type game you usually do motion capture
and you capture all the motion but in
this game we had to do everything by
hand
to have it have that cartoon feel like
you can't capture that so
um again a huge departure is almost like
kind of like relearning but it was good
I think for practicing
like actual skill like you instead of
just kind of copying from you know real
examples which when you make a real game
you pull from resources you pull
you kind of like match you know if it's
an environment you pull from like an
actual building sample or something like
that here it's like okay we need to
design everything so like really kind of
push your
Creative Energy in that sense no respect
um you mentioned before about you know
the studio and I know we talked about
influencers and stuff like that I gotta
ask a second question about my brother
so I wanted to know you know were there
any other you know what's your pedigree
with any what he's saying stuff and
maybe particularly Dreamcast generation
where any other members of the team you
know also have the residents with that
that have familiarity yeah maybe it
worked worked on stuff like that that
they can pull from to help out with
Hi-Fi Rush
yes so a lot of the people especially in
the core group of people who made the
game were all in the same age range so
we kind of had that same inspiration
area to draw from and we would talk
about things you know if it was like the
Dreamcast like talking about I remember
like that feeling of when you saw Jet
Set Radio for the first time or you know
and you felt like oh wow this is this is
finally like cool and they're they're
really like pushing like the medium
um as opposed to like a realistic Style
just something that looked really cool
and so that was for example like in our
perspective but for example on our team
while we did do the initial prototyping
and have all like the action game stuff
worked out eventually we had people
joined who did work in on action games
like for example our lead designer uh a
guy called yamatasan he worked on uh the
original Devil May Cry even like he's
like in classic like the OG of like
action games
and that was where like you had that
initial sort of maybe pushback of like I
don't think this can work because all
the action games I work with like you
couldn't restrict movement like this and
but I was like No just we we got to go
with this because that's what's going to
make us like different than the other
games
um push to push so okay yeah so you you
know it could have been easy just to
like fall back and be like yeah you know
you're right it's you know let's just
make it like a normal action game but
um I think if you have that really
strong Vision you kind of have to like
hold your ground and like really see it
to the end and if if in the end it
doesn't work out then you can you come
back and do it but you know always try
to see what you want to do until like
you get to that that point where you
realize like okay this is as far as I
can take it but um respect I gotta I got
a a secret nugget question that's I'm
the conspiracy theorist right oh my God
all right so don't get the interview
Clan so come on yeah
I used to be I used to be a manager and
a producer of hip-hop artists right and
you say the late 80s early 90s those
late in the 80s early 90s right called
all right so we use the rolling
um TR 80 008 compose a beef machine now
I saw the cat yeah his name is 808. and
am I reaching thinking that there might
be some hip-hop something maybe one day
you know listen
um
no because when I saw it I was like I
said yes man we used to use the 808
drums oh my God and I'm like uh what
What's your history with the compose do
you do you know about the synthesizer
the yes yeah I I I do not
that's what that's that is where the
name came from
um because it's just to me like that
existed before that character or
something existed before we made it as a
cat even it was just like we needed
something for the player to look at over
the shoulder that can keep the beat and
we're like okay this is a metronome this
is something that's keeping the beat and
it's like
you know what's more iconic of like a
beat
anyways so that's where we kind of went
with
um
uh yeah I mean you could the sound
effects that the cat makes is you know
also uh taken from there as well so uh
yeah there was some inspiration there
um which is kind of funny because we
went into like a for a rock angle uh for
this project so it was tricky to like
get the the 808 to like match with it
this is what I was saying I was like
yeah yeah I said I don't know how he did
it I don't I I'm trying to figure it out
because there's other things that I have
to another question later after these
other guys asked questions right oh my
other Lords but um that one was sticking
with me and I was like he's making it
work because I'm I'm listening to the to
the soundtrack and I'm so happy that you
have a stream of soundtrack and you have
the other soundtrack very important
right in this day and age but I'm like
he's making it actually work because
something that you think can't fit and
it does fit and it fits perfectly yeah
no absolutely and and I wanted to to
kind of follow up with what you said in
reference to just making Hi-Fi rush and
to me one of the aspects of that like it
gave being on beat and everything kind
of like linking even the environments is
you know pulsating to the beat the whole
even you know chai himself snapping his
fingers the whole bit you know what
Honestly made me try it because attic
could tell you like we are not the
rhythm game guys let's go be brutally
honest with you like we we generally
don't gravitate towards those because
the mindset is generally when you play
them you know if you fail you don't
Advance right so it's usually very
oppressive but one of the things that
constantly made me try it was that the
the being on beat scene for the most
part additive to the experience you know
like a bonus to the experience you know
what I'm saying as opposed to this super
punishing requirement from stage one and
even stage one I felt was like a great
tutorial like just getting into it
learning it and then I remember getting
to the boss fight I was like oh no
I think they got one with this this is
this is not overrated this is not people
just buying into the to the art style
and everything like that so I guess the
question was for you but for you was the
the Consciousness design to not penalize
as hard for for people like me myself
were terrible at Rhythm games and then
two kind of alluded to what king said
which is about everything being
dependent on the BP and everything being
dependent the art style dependent you
know the transition from 2D to you know
the cutscene the animation dependent on
this beat like what were those technical
challenges to to get everything aligned
with that as well
okay those are two like massively basic
questions
I'll go in order because they're kind of
related but um so the the initial
concept right from the beginning was
this accessibility of of the game
um so like I said also in the pitch
document that the idea is that I wanted
everything to sync up automatically to
the Rhythm because
uh I knew that most people in even if
they have a rhythm sense unless they're
playing to like a UI you know like a
rhythm game when you when you're talking
about like you know prep or dance sense
Revolution you're basically like just
trying to match up things to the UI but
we did want to make it feel like you're
doing that we want to make it feel like
you're in control of the game so in
order to make it feel good we knew that
we needed to kind of sync up everything
on the back end so no matter when you
press the button it's gonna get make you
give you a positive impact basically
where the punch will hit on the beat or
something like that and then then we
said
early on it was like okay let's you know
the the general like game design is like
what you said like if you don't press it
on the right time you'll fail there's
like a fail state right and but the
worst thing they could do is the action
game is just press the button and
nothing happens it feels like it's like
a mistake or something like that so we
switched gears into making everything be
this sort of like positive gameplay Loop
where it's like you don't need to worry
about playing on Rhythm because we'll do
that for you and anytime you need to or
you need to we want you to plan Rhythm
we'll give you some visual aid to do
that but
um we want to give you basically bonuses
for doing that so we're encouraging you
to do that so
the even if you mess up on like the
first input on like a combo or something
if every hit lands on the beat all you
need to do is just when the next hit
hits the character enemy just press the
button again so we're giving you like
lots of ways to sort of even if you mess
up somewhere to kind of jump back on it
and grab on again and that went that was
like our whole philosophy throughout the
game and so we tried to be as leaned as
possible because we knew that you know
like you even said like maybe if Rhythm
games aren't your thing you if it looked
like a rhythm game to you you might have
immediately kind of like turned away but
it looks more like an action game we
don't have those UI on the screen and
things like that
um so that was really important but then
we then this kind of goes to your next
question is is when everything's moving
to the beat it's like how can we make
the player feel even if they're
not using UI that they're kind of
subconsciously in this Zone where they
can feel where the beat is because
that's when we want them to press the
button so we kind of went all out
because we realized they're testing that
some people just their eyes go to
different places they feel different
things like that's why we have the UI
bouncing to the beat we have things in
the environment bouncing the beat we
have we do have assists and we have the
808 over your shoulder help you
um and we realized that some people
thought 808 was super helpful some
people didn't even notice it at all but
some people were looking at the UI yeah
some people saw the environment as a
thing that helped them so we knew like
it had to basically be
we have to make everything go with the
beat
um and that I think is what makes the
package too by making it feel like it's
not just
this small aspect of the game it's like
the whole package of this this this
world that you're playing in is this
you're in this Zone essentially like
um I don't know if any of you play music
um but if you if you if you do work or
or you are like super into it when
you're like really into the music you
almost get into this sort of like trance
type state where you're like really
feeling the beat
um and that's what we're kind of hoping
for people who really jump in and you
know use all the mechanics and and see
what all the enemies are doing and how
the world is moving that you get into
that sort of trans-like Zone where it
just feels like you're like I say like
you're you're playing a part in like the
music video That's being like almost
edited around you oh no Absolutely I'll
tell you what I felt that well during
the uh was it the Rope work boss fight
brofford yeah oh that fight literally
I'm zoning I'm I'm parrying I'm I'm the
beat hitting the Wolf Gang thing is
hitting and first with the characters
are the boss fight is absolutely
somebody like Scrooge McDuck in that
building someone again
I can't explain playing music but
playing your game but we felt like make
me feel like I was a conductor of
something like I was really so that he
could touch me at one point and I really
wanted to thank y'all for that because
that kind of was awesome but I know I'm
asking a ton of questions but I got I
got a question we got to get anecdote
that we got you oh yeah yeah okay what
what I do like this well it's not even a
question it's a statement what I do like
and it's very subtle
when you get a consecutive hits and you
get on that streak you start to see uh
the UI flashing the sound raises and you
get more in tune to the beat and it just
encourages you more
like and I I found myself every time I'm
playing trying to get the music rising
and it just seems like the world just
starts to come more alive because the
more you become on fire so I was just uh
collecting all my like you know every
time I finish a board take a picture
snapshot to show how many
first thing I want to do is give you
props to you know really hyper focusing
around the player experience in this I
feel like that's the difference between
a lot of people making this game and you
making this game where you and your team
is you know because you hyper focused on
the player playing it it was more
enjoyable for the player while they were
playing it so it led to the success of
the game and another question I have
real quick that I was just thinking is
obviously there's a you know Assist
characters in here they pop in when you
press buttons they have certain gameplay
mechanic loops on them uh was that
always the attentions or did you
originally have them on the map with you
and then you figure it out maybe it'd be
easier to do the Hologram way
yes so the assist characters early on we
we did prototype swishing them out like
a different weapon like you'd actually
literally switch the character and
they'd have like different rhythms that
you could attack to but this is
something again that we learned really
on is that you you know when you add in
these super deep features early you can
kind of like blur your vision which was
difficult because most people couldn't
handle switching to a different
character and then adjusting their
Rhythm sense for example like let's say
if you have a peppermint character and
she's going to shoot her gun on like
eighth notes so you need to like kind of
like press them very quickly we realized
that people couldn't quickly switch up
from just a a quarter note like B to
then go to an eighth note beat and it
just wasn't fun
um so then we backed off and said the
best thing that we can do is kind of
make this as simple as and easy as
possible for you to just summon a
character they'll do their thing they'll
help you out and they'll add like their
layer to it and and that's a more
enjoyable experience
yeah
that's a great that's a great point
because yeah I can see how that could
get like really confusing again for
people people like me who you know
struggle with that kind of stuff so yeah
I thought the the interaction was kind
of seamless I wanted to transition from
um kind of like obviously you could talk
about game development you talked about
you know I'm assuming like for four or
five years but um obviously during this
period you know you guys are acquired or
at least Bethesda matches acquired by
Microsoft so I guess the question I have
for you is like you know during that
during that time period I'm assuming no
platform was decided just yet but like
what influence if any did Xbox have as
far as maybe approving something or
saying hey good job or you know where
you guys arrive during the development
process
so interesting enough like you said we
were this game was way into development
before we were acquired by uh Microsoft
but we were still in that sort of period
figuring out you know
What were what was our platform we was
just running on a PC
um and you know we require Microsoft it
was like okay well our platforms decided
that makes sense yeah that was easier
um than you think
um but in a weird way uh you know I
think the the process and I'm not
involved with like the higher up
discussion but you know because there
Xbox has been pretty vocal about have
they been relatively hands off in the
game development process and reeling it
leaving it up to the studios so for us
at our studio we're we were basically
business is always with how we worked
with our team in Bethesda
um we're just going back and forth with
them
and you know the weird thing about how
we also decided to release this game you
know in sort of like a shadow job as
everyone's calling it uh oh yeah you
know
I'm sure that they're probably people in
Microsoft who didn't even know that the
game existed before that point so you
know I don't I don't know because we
kind of kept it internal for a long time
and maybe part of it was because of the
secrecy of it yeah but
um yeah like I said the experience with
the Microsoft you know they didn't
they didn't come in demand anything or
or request anything we just wanted to
make it run as good as we can on on
their platforms and support their
ecosystem you know with like Game Pass
and things like that again real question
um you know obviously this was a shadow
dropped you know that's not really a
practice that's done a lot in this
industry uh but what I want to ask you
is like what were some of the
precautions you guys took to make sure
that this didn't get out of the studio
and like people found out leaked it oh
yeah you know how to go yeah yeah uh
honestly you know maybe until the very
the last like a couple months before
launch like we didn't do anything
special I mean you know anyone who works
on the game like I said I think I
tweeted this out but you know everyone
was like super professional about it you
know normally you get people that go out
and they they immediately talk about
what project they're working on I think
uh
uh you know everyone was very respectful
and and just didn't talk about the game
we never
came down hard it was like you cannot
speak about this game to anyone
it just knew it wasn't announced so
we're not going to talk about it yet
um and then as we got closer to release
or that the point where we're gonna drop
it I think we took a little bit more
precaution you know especially when
making assets who were giving them to
and you know we wanted to keep that
secret because that was like the the
cool key point about our release
um
and that's where I think we kind of
looked at okay let's make sure we're
getting the right people in this meeting
or something like that but before that I
was surprised that
you know there were a lot of people
working on this game you look at the
credits and
and a lot of people again very
respectful on the job that they're doing
so they they just helped out and and
didn't say anything no I got a question
because no please this is this is a good
one okay no I noticed while playing the
game the end game Graphics are
animations are running probably at 60
frames per second right and then when
you go to the like
um
what is it's not full motion but when
you go to the you can't control the cut
scene it go it cuts into like the
Spider-Man into the spider-verse Spidey
verse uh type of animation and I know
that was like thought of on purpose or
was it a a Maga style anime style or you
know current cartoon style that you were
going for as keeping it making everyone
understand that this is a cartoon world
and and leaning heavily into the cartoon
genre
well yeah that was definitely part of it
yeah uh early on we knew that we're
going to try to emulate this sort of uh
2D animation style within a 3D World and
we tried it's called animating on twos
it's like every other frame is animated
um and we did that for the cut scenes
because we tried doing it in game to see
if we can get the characters like
looking like they're moving like that
but it was just again the player
experience was not good it made it look
feel like it's the animation was not
smooth especially for an action game
yeah so that's where we made the
conscious decision to sort of cut it uh
you know when you go into what we call
cut scene or something like that we um
we would we would drop it the frame rate
of the animation
um but again that all all needs to be
calculated you notice it needed to
happen they need to be like a transition
so you wouldn't get the two
jarring to see that so it's like a white
or something like that or the camera
would pan quick and then it would drop
the frame rate and things like that so
everything had to be weirdly
more calculated than we ever needed to
do
it's a nightmare on paper but yeah oh
there's a lot of time and energy today
you could see you know the way you guys
have things aligned you know I wanted to
go back as far as like you know the
influencing like the game does not take
itself seriously that's what I love
about it like it doesn't take it so
seriously and then you've got a lot of
references like as you guys started
diving because one thing you learned
about chai or like he's just ridiculous
like and then I like like the characters
were kind of like kind of pull them in
and get them in in place and say hey no
you're an idiot you really don't have a
plan what are you doing kind of a thing
so I guess my question is like as you're
diving into the over the top this like
was there any fear well job of like hey
wait maybe we pushing it too far like
we're we're really going over the top
ridiculous with this
uh there wasn't really any fear because
that was again one of the one of the key
points was like this is the setting is
ridiculous and does not take itself
seriously uh so we actually wanted to
push for like what's the how far can we
push it
until it gets ridiculous and the only
kind of rule that we had was like
nothing could be really too
mean-spirited you know right
just again it's a game about having a
good time this game having him fun
chives like this kind of like lovable
goofball in a sense but he's never
really like
super super mean Murphy is he's called
out on it or something like that so
that's where we always kind of try to
find like a nice balance but in terms of
the things that happened like if you're
talking about yeah you fight like a
giant werewolf and like a money pit a
shot of a cannon and like into like
cafeteria and stuff like that we wanted
these like again yeah we're just
thinking of these like situations where
it's like you couldn't do this in any
any other game that isn't this and get
away with it
um and yeah but in a way like if like I
said we work in the horror game so it's
very sort of grounded in a way and so it
took a while to get out of our shell of
that once we did I think we we got a
good balance there yeah you guys you
guys are they all did it's absolutely
hilarious that cafeteria seed is
absolutely hilarious yeah oh I want to
go back to what attic said and get
really focused on that magic move
because I think you know for us you know
watching the development of the records
January 25th we're all looking at this
stream you know the Lord's watching and
it's a great stream you know don't got
no doubt but then you know you guys come
up on the screen and we're like what is
this right this looks amazing this looks
cool so I want the temperature of the
studio at that time like the decision
for the shadow Drop Like You know it's a
big deal it's a big deal and and I I
feel like you know I wanted to know like
why that approach as opposed to the
traditional maybe we show it earlier
give them a trailer or something like
that like what ultimately I don't know
if you had to play it in that decision
or the higher-ups did but like what
ultimately led to no let's do it here
this is the right time
uh so we actually did plan on having
like a sort of tease for what the game
was but like way way in advance like at
the worst possible timing like like like
when like the beginning of right when
the coronavirus
yeah so we were planning to do something
around there but then that you know even
like E3 was canceled that year and
um you know okay okay let's let's back
off that for now let's just sit on it
and see what happens you know
um and then as we're getting closer to
release we knew that we knew that a we
had something special we knew that
anyone internally who played it one of
the things they said or you know if
someone saw someone playing looking for
the shoulder they're like hey I want to
play that like now
yeah I don't want to wait I want to play
like right like right now that looks
really fun
and then
um we knew that because it was such a
departure from our studio that maybe the
first like the first jump might be like
hey they're horror Studio making
something not hard can they really pull
it off
um there may be some a little bit
trepidation there and uh but we again we
knew internally we had something that
was very solid and we're very confident
in it and so we kind of wanted this
short marketing campaign at first
um thinking you know like [__] show it
off being like and you could play it
soon like in a month or two months or
something like that like very short
um and then we knew that our release
date was about around that January
period that's what we're kind of aiming
for
we're getting close to that and we're
realizing there's not like a good sort
of like event or something that we can
kind of like stand out and really you
know showcase it without getting
overpowered by something else as well as
in the holiday season games are coming
out people are playing that they're not
paying attention to something might come
out the next year
um so then this idea for the or they
were planning this Xbox developers
direct yes
and we said okay well we're launching
about that same period
um let's basically announce it there and
we didn't even know if we could do a
same day launch originally right so
we're kind of figuring if it's even
possible on like the back end and stuff
like that but uh it turns out it was and
so we kind of said yeah we said let's
try it here and I'll give credit where
it's due it's like that was a marketing
and and PR idea that they're like we can
use this event to basically get everyone
looking at this title for the first time
and get in play right away obviously
from a developer perspective you're
nervous because it is so different than
a normal release cycle so you're even
though you're super confident about the
game and you're and you you're proud
that it's kind of finally be out there
and people gonna be able to play it
you don't know what's going to happen so
you are super nervous so you know we're
we're in our studio freaking out they're
like it's gonna be okay it's going to be
cool
excited about it
um but yeah it's kind of like a sort of
Natural Evolution as you got closer and
saw like okay this is really the the
best opportunity it seems to to launch
the game a quick follow-up before I open
it up like so I understand exactly what
you mean that it's still there's still
got to be a little trepidation does do
you feel like the fact that it uh Hi-Fi
Rush launched in Game Pass impacted to
trajectory of the release in any way as
opposed to let's just say hey it's
standard it's available but go pay 30
for it I mean you obviously you can put
a PC stuff like that but do you feel
that the Game Pass factor maybe it's
still some confidence from from the
marketing standpoint
I think that was absolutely part of it
um so that was a big thing that if we're
launching to Xbox users and they can
most of them I assume are Game Pass
subscribers
um or theoretical Game Pass subscribers
um the fact that we can put this game
out there and say you can play it now
and if you have Game Pass you you it's
basically a demo that you can try you
can get over that hurdle of like hey hey
I don't play Rhythm games this isn't for
me but you give it that first hour or so
and you're like wait no that I can play
this this is for me this is fun and the
quality is there yeah so that was I
think essential to maybe the success
that it had was because we got a lot of
people who probably wouldn't have tried
it out if they had to immediately uh pay
for it
um but we did get those people to to
jump in try it basically be ambassadors
for it and talk about it with other
people as well and share the love in
that sense but um
but yeah uh I think yeah Game Pass was
definitely essential for for how that
strategy worked and paid off wow
impressive impressive I agree King any
thoughts you already know I believe
so so we and what I say over the green
side
um we we watch shows differently and
what we always ask for you know what all
addict always asks for is that um that
moment where Microsoft shows that
theatrics shows clear that yes all right
yeah yeah you you too [__] you cause it
and all right so we're watching the show
and Tango Games comes up and we like
what the hell we didn't know all we knew
was there's supposed to be Forza
Minecraft and and and
um Red Bull yeah so what the hell is
going on and then y'all come out
then we see this game
and we don't watch without wallets
because you know we pay for Game Pass
and then the game drops and they say
right now I really wanted to get off air
so yeah
I'm sitting there not looking we're
looking at like okay let me can I
download it
with the hyphen yeah it's on our live
reaction you can hear him saying that
yeah
literally John ignoring our live
audience and we're trying to get down
here so it got like them
I was gonna say you got people in the
chat able to download it and God's like
well how'd you do it
okay so we know that you know you can
get it in Game Pass and like you said
for some people that want to try it out
to get over that initial hurdle um do I
play Rhythm games or their Studio that
plays uh makes horror games
to see the sales of the game yeah
after the initial tell me how does that
feel because you know you had 30 million
plus people gonna try the game are going
to have the potential to try the game
but to actually the purchasing yeah that
that was us a welcome surprise how how
did the team take it how did you feel
about it uh and I know you've been on a
whirlwind tour but how do you feel about
that that success level from that aspect
well we basically were looking at it
from just like positive sentiment
because that's what we're trying to just
uh at least gauge because we're seeing
everyone play through the game at the
same time and we're seeing them
everyone's saying I'll give it a try
I'll give it a try it's like no no this
is legit this is this game's legit and
then they just keep playing and no one
knows how big the game is how how
anything how you know what it leads to
and everything like that they see like a
low price point and they think it's like
probably like a very short experience or
something like that for
those of you played through it you
probably know that oh yeah there's a lot
of content in this game a lot of content
yeah
um
and uh
and I like I said we're just looking at
more of the sentiment than anything so
everything that we saw that were coming
out from people playing it were like the
same things that you said the same
things that our goals were were about
like the Positive Vibes the positive
like the gameplay Loop the people like
not in the genre but uh are able to
enjoy it as well as like that throwback
feel
um and sort of bringing back what it
feels to just make like have like a fun
game yeah
um so that's like was our big
indicator of success was like hitting
hitting all of our goals as a developer
and and hitting those and and we saw
that in all the comments and we're
actually surprised we thought that some
people might be put off by some of it
we're expecting some people to be like
negative because it like wasn't you know
a horror game or something like that but
it seemed like that was in immediately
like pushed to the side it was like
everyone was so positive about the game
that we were just almost like blown away
because yeah it it was risky from like a
gay development perspective but it just
felt like it paid off in that aspect
yeah no doubt I agree addict yeah uh
because I know we're coming up on the
end of the show I just got a couple
questions that I can go through real
fast here uh from uh you know our
audience
um so hard I find says will there be a
box version for this if you guys are
thinking about doing one
like a physical release is that on the
plans in any way shape or form
where we saw that there's a lot of
requests for that so we're thinking but
you know we're we're looking into what
that would be about but we don't have
any announcements for it
yeah
[Laughter]
the collector's edition would be nice
too I'm just saying you you don't gotta
say that yeah
Anthony said is there any hidden secret
eggs that uh secret Easter eggs that
hasn't been found yet to your knowledge
you believe in like finding a lot of the
stuff we thought we wouldn't find so I
don't know if everything has been found
um there's some pretty like well-hidden
stuff but
I have to have to scour the injury to
see if everyone's found everything
and then the last question by Dragon
yarby uh you know I'm gonna reword it
because uh if if someone like Netflix or
something approached you guys to make an
animated version of this would that be
something you would like to see not that
I'm not asking I said would you like to
see this in an animated version Oh I
think that's like the dopest Eddie ever
heard that but coming back
that's all the questions that I could
ask you
I am so because like kick this to be
again screams like Saturday morning
cartoon videos
anime style like I could see it like
I've already you know my marketing I'm
into the toys
808 to be already on the Mount Rushmore
for mascots for Xbox
you know but
it's been tremendous to see the success
you know and again the way you guys
handling the development you know the
the just the attention to detail funds
colorful it's vibrant you know it's just
like this motley crew and they just get
together to kind of form to be a group
or be like a band like literally like a
bed like coming together like a bed and
stuff like that I did want to ask real
quick I think Celeste about the PC Port
possible I don't know if you have
anything to do with that though really
outstanding you know outstanding PC Port
when you had to handle that was a
separate team for that oh no we did that
all internally
um regretted I'm not like a PC player
but
like one of the baselines were like this
needs to be our best PC Port
um even though it looks like it it isn't
an intensive game because of like the
graphics uh that's very deceiving
because it is
um but our I was like people are going
to assume that
it probably doesn't need a lot of like
power to run even though it does
um so I said we have to do the best that
we can so it runs like a hard 60 frames
per second on even like these low
settings
um we want as much people to experience
as possible so uh yeah we worked really
hard to optimize that thing so
um it would be a good piece of report
yeah yeah thank you sorry yeah and the
Steam Reviews seem to show that because
people seem to love it so that was our
biggest concern it's so hard to
calculate there's so many different
configurations for PC stuff
um you can only do so much but uh I
think our team kind of like really just
hit out of the park in that sense
because it works great on a lot of PCS
absolutely shout out to the entire team
on that the pop just the overall polish
of this game this is tremendous and I
really hope you guys get said our love
to the teams because you know obviously
the different platforms you're talking
about PC all the configurations you know
you're on the series actually on a
series actually you know and and that's
one of the things that really stood out
to me like wow not only this game look
good plays good the combat is amazing
the combo potential I made like a whole
Parry build you know it it's so many
things you could do it according to your
playstyle but the overall polish was one
of the things that really stood out so
salute to you guys on that and then um
yeah like the final question that we
asked all the the members of the realm
that we got to ask Lord John is um kind
of your top five video games or
franchises of all time any order you
know of all time oh my God no pressure
no pressure
it's all the pressure
oh wow okay uh I feel like it changes a
lot but
um
as of today
uh so I'm a huge fan of bloodborne on
PS4 okay okay it's just a huge fan of
like the environment there
um Shadow of the Colossus
it's always a good one
um
go talk I want to say this because
I know that you can answer it to this
but I have so many hours clocked in
Destiny too you are welcome back on the
show
Andy time
what's up class sir what's up class
would you do I'm a Titan
no yeah but I had to actually stop
because like I just was not getting any
work done
look I need you to finish these games
man
yeah
oh my God yeah but I just let Destiny by
the amount of time played I think
Destiny's got to be up there
um yeah that's three that's three two
more all right oh my God uh Mr President
or anything that the franchise that are
important to you
oh my God it could be like okay yeah
uh I would say
um
I always go back and play Castlevania
Symphony of the Night oh solve would be
going crazy right now uh I think you're
the first one to ever say that too yeah
and I know it just came out as a
remaster but I always love Metroid Prime
oh
um it's just like great like World
building immersion things like that yeah
um
the final one no we can't answer that
last question
oh no no you know why I'm not gonna ask
him that last question let's leave the
last question we gotta find out what his
favorite console of all time okay all
right what's his favorite castle of all
time just curious
um I was a Dreamcast
you was all scared
all right
look man Little Johnny absolute pleasure
John John I love being here yeah oh man
you killed it an absolute pleasure where
can the five people find you what else
do you have going on let the people know
man this was an absolute pleasure to
have you uh you can find me on Twitter
my name is literally my name it's John
Johannes
um otherwise please follow Hi-Fi Rush
Twitter count play it uh if you if you
don't have Game Pass don't worry it's
only 30 dollars not a big buried entry
but even if it's up you think it's not
up your alley I say please give it a try
yes you're almost guaranteed to love it
take it from these guys as well
we appreciate you Lord Eddie Let's uh
any final words for Lord John on his way
out yeah you know one thing I have to
appreciate you John you and your team
like you kept the player in the center
you don't want to come to how the PC
performed to come do want to make sure
the game performed well when it comes to
you know redirecting how you initially
envisioned the game to make sure the
player was always the center of the
focus and I have a say on here it's like
you know you make good games you get
rewarded and I I think that everything
that's happened to your game came with
the hard work that you and your team do
absolutely no thank you thank you yeah
call came play Sean through Lord King
and we follow words for the legendary
John Johannes
John um
you brought back a feeling that I didn't
think uh that I would get in video games
for a while right my the Dreamcast was
probably the greatest launch in the
history of video games 15 must-have
titles at launch
um Jet Set Radio
blew my mind
and um when I saw this game it just took
me back to when games were just fun
preach just absolutely fun and you're
going through the worlds you're finding
things in and I play the game and I I
feel a little bit of Devil May Cry I
feel uh the combo system I I feel a lot
of you know when you first play Sonic
and you notice that the world was alive
too it's it was just so many different
things that I'm finding and I'm falling
in love with the game as I go on and go
further into the game I replay levels
just to check stuff that see if I got
stuff
um I just want to say thank you I just
want to say thank you and you were there
to do a job in Japan and on a whim you
filled out for another job I love that
story and you was there and then you
find like this purpose and his purpose
was to bring joy and I asked you the
question about sales and you said you
know it's not really about that it was
just about the vibe the good energy
given out
and I really truly appreciate that so
that's why I was having so much success
and I wish you so much more success and
I I can't wait to see the hip-hop
version
you influenced
but I do appreciate everything that you
guys have done and um I look forward to
future endeavors it was a fantastic uh
interview and thank you so much for
sharing your time now thank you that was
what you everything you just said was
exactly what we wanted to hear when we
were making the game so thank you so
much an absolute pleasure the legendary
John Joe hot is high five Rush one of
the hottest literally secret drops of
2023 oh man what more can we say look
forward to hearing from you and the team
looking forward to see what you guys got
cooking and again thank you so much for
your time the legend and Tango and
Bethesda in the building salute thank
you so much brother have a good one
thank you please